resolvamos 240 entre 3 para resolver
esto podríamos tomar este número de tres
dígitos y dividirlo entre este número de
un dígito o podríamos usar lo que
sabemos de los ceros y las decenas para
descomponer esto en números que serían
más fáciles de trabajar este 240 como
tengo un cero al final sabemos que es lo
mismo que 24 decenas o 24 x 1024 por 10
y cualquier número que multiplicamos por
10 tendrá el número original en este
caso 24 tendrá un cero al final 240 así
que 240 es lo mismo que 24 decenas o 24
por 10 así que este número aquí lo
podemos descomponer como 24 por 10 y
esto lo seguimos dividiendo entre 3 aquí
cambiamos este 240 ó 24 decenas como 24
por 10 lo que no modificamos fue la
solución estas expresiones son
equivalentes van a ser igual al mismo
número así que podemos resolver
cualquiera de ellas y tendremos la misma
solución y aquí abajo tenemos unos
números más sencillos para trabajar así
que vamos a usar estos de abajo lo
siguiente que vamos a hacer es tomar
este 24 x 10 y cambiarle el orden yo sé
que la multiplicación no importa el
orden de los factores por ejemplo si yo
tengo algo como 2 x 3
esto va a ser igual a 3 por 2 2 por 3 es
igual a 6 y 3 por 2 es igual a 6 también
por lo que podemos cambiar el orden sin
cambiar la respuesta vamos a hacer esto
de este lado 10 por 24 dividido entre 3
cambiamos el orden de lo que está
escrito aquí pero no cambiamos su valor
por lo que no cambiamos la solución y
ahora puedo ver una división que es
mucho más sencilla para mí al menos
comparándola con esta división de un
número de tres dígitos
4 dividido en grupos de 3 va a ser igual
a 8 esto es 8 y bajamos la
multiplicación de 10 bajamos este 10 y
el signo de multiplicar y usamos el
patrón del que hablamos aquí arriba
cuando multiplicamos por 10 tomamos
nuestro número y le agregamos un 0 al
final y nos queda 80 nuestra solución es
80 por lo que la solución de la
expresión original también es 80 240
dividido entre 3 es igual a 8 decenas y
80 otra forma en la que podemos pensar
en esto es ver a 240 como ya lo habíamos
mencionado 24 decenas y si dividimos 24
decenas entre 3 nos van a quedar ocho
decenas ocho decenas es igual a 80 así
que esto es otra forma en la que pudimos
pensar en este problema ya sea usar lo
que sabemos del cero o nuestro
conocimiento de las decenas para
descomponer este problema de división
de manera que no tengamos que trabajar
con un número de tres dígitos sino con
números más pequeños y sencillos vamos a
resolver otro problema un poquito más
complicado digamos que tenemos 42
centenas o 4200 dividido entre digamos
que 7 aquí podemos descomponer este
número de 4.200 ó 42 centenas podemos
reescribirlo como 42% ya que nuestro
patrón nos dice que si tenemos un número
entero como 42 y lo multiplicamos por
100 mantendremos nuestro número entero
en este caso 42 y le agregaremos dos
ceros 42% y ponemos nuestra división
entre 7 intercambiamos estos números
para que nos quede 100 por 42 entre 7
ahora el 42 y el 7 están juntos y esto
lo hacemos así porque es muy probable
que esta división la conozcamos si
dividimos 42 en grupos de 7 nos va
quedar 6 bajamos el 100 y el símbolo de
multiplicación 100 por 6 nos da 600 por
lo que nuestra solución de lo que
teníamos aquí arriba 4200 entre 7 va a
ser igual a 600 o también pudimos usar
el valor posicional usando palabras en
lugar de dígitos 4.242 centenas lo
escribimos 42 centenas y si dividimos 42
centenas entre grupos de 7 cada grupo
tendrá 6 centenas 600 de cualquier
manera 4.242 centenas divididas entre 7
es igual a 600 y así pudimos resolver un
problema un poquito complicado con un
número de cuatro dígitos sin tener que
realizar una división larga en su lugar
usamos lo que sabemos del valor
posicional de las centenas y los ceros